Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Scheiß AfD. Moment, bitte. Scheiß AfD.
Das ist extrem laut im Hintergrund hier. Scheiß AfD.
Entschuldigung. Ich kann dich kaum verstehen.
Scheiß AfD. Ich habe jetzt ein Rekord auf dem Ohr. Jetzt geht gar nichts mehr. Scheiß AfD.
Jetzt höre ich mich doppelt. Ich höre mich auf.
Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD.
Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD.
Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD,
Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD Demonstranten hier!
Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD, Scheiß AfD.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 529 vom 24.
Sommer? Juli. Juli. Juli. Juli.
Juli 2025. La la la la la. Es ist Sommer.
Interview.
Da geht man doch ins Freie. Da ist es schön.
Wir setzen uns an die Spree und unterhalten uns über Politik.
Da kommt der Bus.
Für den unwahrscheinlichen Fall, dass ihr das nicht mitbekommen habt.
Aber es gab so ein Sommerinterview. Von wem war das eigentlich? ARD oder ZDF?
ARD macht das Sommerinterview. Ich glaube auch mit anderen Politikerinnen und
Vertreterinnen der im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien.
Und mit anderen Vertreterinnen der AfD.
Oh Mann ey. man fragt sich wirklich, wie der Entscheidungsprozess bei denen eigentlich so läuft.
Also die anderen Sommerinterviews, ich gucke jetzt nicht irgendwie regelmäßig
Sommerinterviews, aber die finden schon an diesem Ort da statt. Aber,
also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es im ARD Hauptstadtstudio,
aber auch bei der Berliner Polizei im Anschluss so eine, weißt du,
so ein ich würde das dann, also ich würde so den Invite würde ich so,
Post Mortem oder Lessons Learned, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
stand so in dem Invite drin,
wo dann irgendeiner reinkommt und erstmal so eine Minute ruhig auf und ab geht
und um Worte ringt und dann irgendwann fragt,
Wer von euch war so scheiße doof?
Wie konnten wir das nicht vorhersehen?
Ja, was ist passiert? Also Alice Weidel saß in diesem Sommerinterview und wurde
befragt, beziehungsweise es wurde versucht, sie zu befragen.
Und dann fuhr dahinter, ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Abstand,
der Adenauer, laut Buchnetz-Politik-Hörer wissen genau, worum es geht.
Erst war der nicht da. Also schon die Demonstrantinnen, die da waren, waren laut genug.
Der Adenauer kam etwas später noch dazu, um das Finale zu setzen sozusagen.
Also nicht von Beginn an.
Ja, also hier war ein schönes Lied, was da gespielt wurde von der ARD.
Und irgendwie hat es die Beteiligten am Mikrofon ein bisschen aus dem Konzept
gebracht. Sowas würde uns ja nie passieren.
Nein. Genau, das ist ein Sample vom Cornerchor, ein Chor aus Augsburg,
der schon seit eigentlich einiger Zeit sehr ausführlich vom Adenauer abgespielt
wird und auch jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal in einem Fernsehbeitrag es schafft, gehört zu werden.
Allerdings wurden am Adenauer die Soundanlage in den letzten Monaten nochmal um einiges optimiert.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist die Sirene gewichen.
In unserer Folge zum Adenauer, in der Folge 516 ist in den Show Notes verlinkt,
über Sirenen gesprochen und es gab dann irgendwann die Entscheidung,
dass da eben was anderes hin muss und das ist tatsächlich eine Soundanlage, die auf so,
auf so einer Armgerüstkonstruktion ist, wo man die in beide Richtungen des Fahrzeugs bewegen kann.
Also du hast dann so eine Fernbedienung und dann klappen halt diese Lautsprecher,
weil du weißt ja nicht, in welche Richtung du beschallen musst.
Und deswegen sind die tatsächlich diese riesigen.
Lautsprecher, kannst du dann mit so einer Kranfahrerfernbedienung,
weißt du, wo du so einen Knopf drückst und dann geht man so dann kannst du die
auf die rechte oder auf die linke Seite legen.
Und die sind halt laut.
Also der Ort, wo dieses Sommerinterview gedreht wird, der ist ja auf der einen Spree-Seite.
Da an der Brücke quasi, die zum Hauptstadtstudio führt. Ich weiß nicht,
ist das die Reinhardtstraße oder was?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Nee, Reinhardtstraße ist ja nicht.
Auf jeden Fall die Brücke, das Hauptstadtstudio ist an einer Straße gelegen und an der Spree.
Da ist eine Brücke und auf der anderen Seite wird das gedreht und von dort aus
wiederum quasi direkt an dem, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das...
Schiff, Bauerdamm und Reichstagsufer.
Genau, das ist auf der anderen Seite, aber da, wo das gedreht wird,
das ist, warte mal, das ist ein Bundestagsgelände wahrscheinlich.
Dieses Gebäude.
Also wenn es auf der anderen Seite der Spree ist, dann ist es da,
wo früher mal RTL war, glaube ich, am Schiff, Bauerdamm.
Aber ist ja eigentlich auch egal. Auf jeden Fall auf der anderen Seite.
Aber das ist dann die Kurve und da ist, du siehst ja, die Kurve siehst du dann
den Reichstag und da siehst du diese Sackgasse, die quasi zwischen Reichstag
und Paul-Löwe-Haus ist.
Und da stellt sich dann ja der Adenauer hin und ballert einmal.
Also wirklich, der ist jetzt nicht besonders nah dran.
Und schafft es aber eben, da durch einen gezielten Audio-Strom die komplett
aus dem Konzept zu bringen.
Ja, den Gedankenstrom lahmzulegen.
Und man hört das auch einfach das gesamte Sommerinterview durch.
Alles, was dafür, ja. Das muss man schon gesehen haben, das ist durchaus ein
Moment Fernsehgeschichte.
Definitiv.
Ja, okay, also wir waren amüsiert und schön, dass das mal ein bisschen interveniert
wurde, weil dieses permanente Zurschaustellen der AfD im Fernsehen, das geht einfach nicht.
Nee, aber du weißt doch, Tim, durch diese Intervention des Adenauer wurde ja
jetzt verhindert, dass die AfD in diesem Sommerinterview entzaubert wurde.
Jetzt müssen wir uns nicht wundern. Jetzt müssen wir uns nicht wundern, dass die AfD...
Gott, die Entzauberer der AfD.
Auf jeden Fall. Die besten Diskussionsbeiträge zu dieser Aktion.
Das ist auch schon wirklich... Ach, und dann müssen sie alle,
irgendwelche bedeutungsschwangeren Interpretationen und warum das jetzt falsch
war und warum das besser gewesen wäre, der Alice Beiland einfach,
weiß nicht, noch mehr Sendezeit zu geben, um ihre Scheiße da zu erzählen.
Tja, also ich glaube, um da ordentlich zu entzaubern, müsste man der ARD erstmal
einen Entzauberkasten schicken. dann können sie erstmal ein bisschen mit üben.
Ja, also wunderschöne Aktion hat natürlich jetzt auch Strafanzeige und so weiter,
nach sich gezogen. Das wird auf jeden Fall wieder,
a gift that keeps on giving.
Ja, wir sind auch wieder da. Wir hatten eine kleine technische Pause und hatten
in der letzten Sendung wieder mal sehr ausführlich eure Kommentare aufgegriffen.
Was dazu führt, dass wir mehr kriegen.
Genau.
Sodass wir jetzt wieder in der Situation sind, das nicht komplett ignorieren
zu können, wie es eigentlich unsere Art ist.
Also gehen wir nochmal ein bisschen auf das ein.
Da ist auf jeden Fall viel Debatte gewesen, vor allem natürlich rund um das KI-Thema.
Das ist auch sehr schön, das war ja auch ein bisschen beabsichtigt.
Ja, und ein paar Sachen picken wir jetzt nochmal raus, aber wir machen es nicht ganz so lang diesmal.
Tim, wenn wir sagen, wir machen keine lange Sendung, dann wird das irgendwie Mitternacht.
Das stimmt.
Leg ich los.
Das Erste hast du bekommen, oder?
Ach so, ah ja, stimmt. Genau, eine E-Mail, also es war per E-Mail von Philipp,
der nochmal auch sehr schön was zusammengefasst hat, was wir in der Sendung
nicht so schön formuliert haben.
In Bezug auf die Frage, ob sich das Geschäftsmodell für KI-Anbieter rechnet,
Habe ich mit Blick auf den privaten Gebrauch die Sorge, dass sich eine ähnliche
Entwicklung wie beim World Wide Web abzeichnet?
Für den Großteil der Nutzerinnen wird es vor allem um Konsum gehen.
Und Relevanz könnte zunehmend durch Sichtbarkeit ersetzt werden.
Schon heute optimieren SEO-Agenturen Inhalte gezielt darauf,
in LLM-Antworten aufzutauchen. auch die Kooperation von OpenAI mit Plattformen
wie Shopify deuten in diese Richtung.
Philipp verlinkt dann noch Essays zu dem Thema, die auch unter unvollständig.de
bei uns in den Show Notes verlinkt sind.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine schreckliche Vorstellung und auch eine sehr
realistische leider, weil ja heute schon im Prinzip kein Internet nach dem zehnten
Google-Treffer, so ungefähr.
Du findest im Internet quasi nicht statt, wenn du nicht unter den ersten zehn
Google-Treffern bist. Aber da gibt es wenigstens noch zehn Google-Treffer.
Und wenn jetzt deine AI das Interface ist, den Browser ersetzt,
die Vielfalt des Internets, dann hast du hier quasi.
Das könnte halt das neue kommerzielle Interface sein, was optimiert wird durch
Berieselung und so weiter.
Und dann waren die Zentralisierungstendenzen beim World Wide Web quasi ein Lacher
gegen das, als wir einfach mal so ein LLM das World Wide Web haben lesen lassen
und es dadurch im Prinzip abgeschafft haben.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Vision, die Philipp hier entfaltet.
Und related gibt es jetzt die ersten Studien,
die so feststellen, der Einsatz dieser KI-Zusammenfassung auf Suchergebnisseiten,
wie man sie jetzt auch bei Google langsam immer mehr bekommt,
führt zu einer deutlichen Änderung in dem Verhalten der NutzerInnen,
nämlich ungefähr nur noch halb so viele Klicken auf die Links.
Das heißt, die Menschen, und das ist ja auch verständlich, weil die Menschen
suchen ja Antworten, nicht Empfehlungen, wo man die Antwort finden kann.
Und wenn du ihnen direkt die Antwort gibst, warum sollen die dann noch die Empfehlungen klicken?
Es klickt ja auch keiner, es liest ja auch keiner die Fußnoten oder die Belege in einem Artikel.
Wenn die Antwort doch da ist, dann kann ich doch die nächste Frage stellen oder
so. Das ist schon durchaus ein...
Ja, also da steckt echt eine Menge drin. Also kann ja dem Ganzen natürlich auch
wieder so einen optimistischen Spin geben.
Also durch KI ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, dieser Suchmarkt schon in eine gewisse
Disruptionsphase gekommen.
Und Google da in dem Moment seinen Platz behalten kann, ist nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich,
aber eigentlich auch noch offen, ist noch nicht beantwortet und derzeit.
Sind wir ja in dieser Phase der totalen Überschätzung von KI.
Und kann also durchaus sein, dass wir da auch noch ein Rollback erleben werden.
So oder so ist ja das, was die Textzusammenfasser, die KI, LLMs machen,
ist ja eigentlich Wissen liefern.
Und Suchmaschinen liefern Orte.
Das gab auch schon so eine Übergangsphase, so dieses Antworten zusammenfassen
und so ist ja jetzt nichts Neues.
Also es wurde ja auch schon aus Metadaten, Wikidata und Wikipedia und so weiter
auch schon, wenn man nach irgendwas sucht, schon mal gesagt wurde,
ja das ist ein Sidebar, in dem das steht.
Also das war jetzt auch vor den LLMs schon ein Ding, weil eben oft Leute,
wie du schon richtig sagst, Antworten auf Fragen suchen eigentlich bei Google.
Während es eben klassisch eigentlich das Web-Directory war und man eben erwartet,
dass diese Informationen auf den Webseiten sind und dass die SEOs da jetzt auch mitgehen und sagen,
okay, der Content, den wir im Internet platzieren, muss uns irgendwie thematisch abbilden.
Und das ist natürlich auch eine große Gefahr einer inhaltlichen Verzerrung und
diese Beeinflussung sehen wir natürlich jetzt auch von Bad Actors,
die so ihre alternativen Realitätsdarstellungen natürlich dann auch versuchen überall zu posten,
damit eben möglichst die LLMs sich daraus ernähren künftig und ihr Wissen sozusagen
daraus zusammenstellen.
Genau, aber ich würde das noch eine Ecke weiterdenken. Ja, Google...
Ist angefangen als eine Suchmaschine, die dir Orte empfiehlt,
verdient aber das Geld damit, dass man sich die Empfehlungen ja kaufen kann.
Hier wäre eine richtige Suche und hier gibt es einen Link. Hier gibt es ein
Adword oder was auch immer das dann heißt.
Also man schaltet Werbung auf Google. Das heißt, die haben die Macht ihrer Empfehlungen
ja verstanden und gesagt, alles klar, das werden wir zu monetarisieren.
Also angenommen das Interface der Zukunft ist, so wie ChatGPT oder ist sogar
nur noch irgendwie ein Gerät, was mit dir spricht,
dann wäre jetzt zum Beispiel der klassische Weg, ich möchte irgendwie ein Produkt
einer bestimmten Gattung kaufen.
Dann informiert man sich, was ist der beste, was weiß ich, Luftreiniger oder
Rasenmäher oder Küchenmesser oder was auch immer.
Und dann guckt man auf Idealo, wo das Billigste ist, mit Versand ohne und so weiter.
Aber wenn sich das Interface ändert und man sagt, ich will einen Luftreiniger
haben, welchen will ich denn haben?
Dann ist ja dieser gesamte Schritt.
Erledigt. Und wenn das ergeben, dann sagt das Ding, ja okay,
ich sag dir mal, wie man Luftreiniger kauft, wie groß soll der Raum sein?
Ich sag dir mal, wie groß du den Küchenmesser kaufst? Ich empfehle dir Folgendes.
Alternativen sind die anderen drei. Dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass du ja nur das wahrnimmst, was dir da angeboten wird, natürlich enorm groß.
Und dass das Modell dahin optimiert, wo es eventuell den besten Profit bekommt,
das machen ja Google, Amazon und sonstige auch heute schon.
Das heißt, wenn sich hier das Interface ändert, dass diese Vielfalt weg ist
und dann die meisten Menschen überhaupt diese Technologie-KI gar nicht mehr nutzen,
um selber kreativ zu sein oder sonst was, sondern einfach nur,
um ihre Konsumentscheidungen gestalten zu lassen und,
Dann haben wir uns irgendwie über die Manipulationsmacht von Google und Facebook lange genug aufgeregt.
Ja gut, ich meine was Kaufentscheidungen betrifft, das ist ja nur nichts Neues.
Ich mache mir mehr Sorgen über die Wissensentscheidungen und die Geschichte.
Ebenfalls verstehen.
Ja.
Gut. Ein zweiter Kommentar kam von Marc.
Es gab mehrere Kommentare zu dem
Thema, aber ich greife jetzt mal hier nur einen raus zum Thema Energie.
Wir haben halt angesprochen Energie und es gab unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu,
wie es sich denn nun wirklich verhält. Marc schreibt zum Thema Limitierung durch Energie.
Fakt ist, dass seit ca.
2080 folgendes Verhältnis nicht wesentlich geändert hat.
Der gesamte Stromverbrauch der Welt kann durch PV auf einer Fläche von etwa
Österreich unter guten idealen Bedingungen abgedeckt werden.
Steigender Stromverbrauch und Effizienzgewinne in PV haben sich da über 20 Jahre die Waage gehalten.
Nun ist das nicht alle Energie, die gebraucht wird, schon klar,
aber dass Energie auf lange Sicht ein limitierender Faktor für uns ist,
halte ich für eine Annahme, die noch weit weg von Relevanz ist.
Limitierend ist vor allem die Old Fossil Economy, die ihre Pfründe verteidigt
und wenn man sieht, wie weit die Profiteure dieser Ökonomie sich durch die gesamte
Wirtschaft zieht, scheint mir da das wesentlichere und akutere Problem zu liegen.
By the way, die Bitcoin-Economy ist da nochmal eine Ausnahme,
weil die ja vor allem von den Kosten der Energieerzeugung abhängig ist,
sinken die Kosten der Energieerzeugung, steigt automatisch der für das Aufrechterhalten
der Blockchain notwendige Energieverbrauch.
Das ist ein nie mehr behebbarer Konstruktionsfehler dieser Sache und meines
Erachtens der wesentliche Totengräber der Technologie.
PV-Photovoltaik, wir nehmen das jetzt einfach so zur Kenntnis.
Wir sind keine Energie-Photovoltaik.
Ich würde einfach nur, also wovon wir uns, wovon ich erstmal ausgehen würde
ist, wenn wir Energiegewinnungsmöglichkeiten schaffen und entwickeln und bauen,
dann wird diese Energie auch verbraucht werden.
Was nicht passieren wird ist, dass Leute sagen, ach geil, wir haben irgendwie,
lass mal anfangen Energie zu sparen.
Das findet nicht so.
Da sind wir in allen Bereichen recht schlecht aufgestellt.
Also ich verstehe ja, dass wir jetzt hier gerade eine viele in der Diskussion
befindliche neue Technologiebewegung haben,
wo viel Bad Player am Start sind und deswegen regt das alle auf und das ist ja auch in Ordnung so.
Deswegen richtet sich die ganze Aufmerksamkeit halt jetzt auf deren Energieverbrauch.
Aber es gibt halt auch sehr viel Konsumverhalten, sonstige Dinge,
die auch eine ganze Menge Energie verbrauchen.
Und wir müssen das Problem in der Gesamtheit lösen.
Also da jetzt nur so oft ein Ding drauf zu hauen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt nur die KI-Technologie allein jetzt auf einmal
alles rausreißt und dann war es das mit dem Planeten.
Und hätten wir das jetzt nicht gemacht, wäre alles gut gewesen.
Also wir müssen da an vielen Fronten kämpfen.
Johannes schreibt zu KI und Proteinfaltung. Linus und alle Interessierten sollten
sich unbedingt die Vorträge von David Baker, Demis Hassabis und John Jumper
anschauen, die sie in Stockholm im Rahmen der Nobelpreisverleihung gehalten
haben. Link in den Shownotes.
Stellt man sich eine Kette aus Aminosäuren vor, die als sequenzieller Abdruck
aus DNS oder RNS entstanden ist, kann man sich überlegen, dass mit jedem Aminosäureglied
die Restkette nach links oder rechts knicken kann.
Also sollte man vielleicht nochmal kurz vorher sagen, wir hatten über diese
Komplexität, die da sich abspielt, gesprochen.
Hier eine kurze Erläuterung, wie diese Komplexität ist. Also er schreibt weiter.
Dann hat man allein schon einen auf Basis zwei exponentiell anwachsenden Möglichkeitenraum,
wie sich ein sich dann ergebendes Protein darstellt.
Zusätzlich wirken noch viele andere chemische und physikalische Effekte auf
die endgültige Form ein.
So wie es Tim formulierte, ein einziger Fehlknick links drehen statt rechts
drehen kann zum Beispiel ein sonst wirksames Medikament zu einem Gift machen.
Unser Körper besteht aus geschätzt 120 Billionen Zellen.
In und zwischen diesen Zellen schwimmen und werkeln jeweils tausende,
zehntausende Proteinroboter und Proteinbauteile.
Wer sich jetzt mal auf die Hand schaut und versucht geistig rein zu zoomen,
kommt am Bild eines umherwandelnden Ameisenhaufens auf Steroiden nicht vorbei.
Das ist fast überwältigend. Eine hervorragende Doku mit beeindruckenden Animationen.
Dazu sind hier auch noch in den Links von der Mediathek und BBC zu finden.
Super, das baue ich mir an. Nicht mehr zu sagen, außer genau,
also das ist halt ein hartes Feld und umso bemerkenswerter ist es,
dass man also jetzt hier an dieser Stelle mit Machine Learning Lösungen gefunden
hat, da hier die Voraussetzungen zu machen. Den nächsten darfst du mal machen.
Genau, das ist das Thema KI-Therapeutinnen oder Psychologen.
Dazu kommentiert Nils. Zum Thema KI-Psychologen. Ein Verwandter von mir war
jetzt gerade für sechs Wochen in einer psychosomatischen Klinik aufgrund von Depressionen.
Er berichtete mir zu meinem Erstaunen, dass von seinen 30-40 Mitpatientinnen
annähernd 100% KI regelmäßig in Bezug auf Hilfe bei psychischen Problemen nutzen.
Allerdings war der Altersdurchschnitt wohl auch eher niedrig, so im Bereich 20-40.
Dabei ersetzt die KI natürlich nicht die Therapeutin, aber gerade für Personen,
die Probleme haben, ihre Gedanken und Gefühle einzuordnen oder auch Alltagsaufgaben
zu strukturieren, scheint KI ein sehr taugliches Mittel zu sein.
Außerdem steht KI rund um die Uhr zur Verfügung ohne Ermüdungserscheinungen
und auch ohne Spezialisierung kennt KI Coaching und Therapieverfahren und kann
darauf basierend antworten.
Manche bauen sich eine Art Live-Coach-KI, die mit relevanten Kontextdaten zur
eigenen Person gefüttert wird und passende Coaching-Anweisungen hinterlegt hat,
sodass die Kommunikation sehr hilfreich und auch zugewandt erlebt wird.
Das ist schön. Während wir hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik noch darüber diskutieren,
helfen die Leute, die leiden, sich einfach selber.
Ich muss aber inhaltlich trotzdem ergänzen, dass es eine noch nicht peer-reviewte
Studie der Stanford University gibt,
die im Juni vorgestellt wurde, wo sie systematisch die Reaktionen,
verbreiteter Chat-Modelle wie Chat-GPT auf Szenarien im Zusammenhang mit psychischen
Erkrankungen untersucht haben.
Sie haben da Prompts reingeschrieben, die auf bestimmte Störungsbilder schließen ließen.
Und üblicherweise zeigten diese Systeme eben diskriminierende Muster und teilweise
Antworten, die grundlegende therapeutische Leitlinien missachteten.
Also irgendjemand, der sagt, ich bin irgendwie depressiv und so und so weiter
und dann halt eine halbe Stunde später sagt, wo ist denn hier mal die nächste Brücke oder so.
Dass dann Chachipiti sagt, Brücke, Wasser oder Beton?
Und interessant, also das ist ja zu erwarten, also dass das gegen psychisch.
Besondere Menschen oder diagnostizierte Menschen sich diskriminatorisch verhält,
ist zu erwarten auf Basis des Lernmaterials.
Das machen unsere Gesellschaften.
Und unser Internet ist recht. Das heißt, das ist relativ erwartbar,
dass das System sich da diese Ideen mitlernt und diese Tendenzen mitlernt.
Aber was auch Sie sagen, Sie haben dann in dieser Studie kommerzielle,
KI-gestützte Therapie-Chatbots, die also quasi spezifisch auf Therapien abzielen, untersucht.
Und die haben noch schlechter abgeschlossen.
Da würde ich wiederum sagen, ja, weil die nicht so viele Daten haben. Noch nicht.
Das wird dann jetzt demnächst irgendwie, werden die ganzen Therapie-Sessions,
transkribiert, kriegst du die Therapie kostenlos, wenn die schön mitgeschnitten
werden darf und nachher als Lernmaterial für irgendein LLM. Das werden die alles hinkriegen.
Also hier ist die Realität hinter meiner Prognose noch hinterher.
Aber der Co-Autor Nick Haber betont, dass er sagt, eine pauschale Verurteilung ist hier fehl am Platz.
Die Technik hat in diesem Bereich prinzipiell Potenzial.
Die genaue Rolle muss jetzt halt noch definiert werden. Also die sagen,
das ist eine Momentaufnahme, nicht eine Zukunftsprognose, was die da jetzt erfasst haben.
Alright, dann auch zum Thema KI und Programmieren kam noch etwas.
Das war, sagen wir mal so bunt gemischt zwischen, ich benutze das,
das läuft super, hilft mir sehr und ich habe das mal ausprobiert und das ist
alles eine totale Katastrophe.
Hier mal ein Beispiel von Chris. Zum Thema KI in der Softwareentwicklung,
den Mehrwert von LLMs zum Schreiben von Dokumentationen kann ich mir noch nicht vorstellen.
Bisher war die Dokumentation, die ich von LLMs gesehen habe,
nur Beschreibung, was der Code tut und damit wertlos für jede Person,
die den Code lesen kann, der nicht total schrecklich schlecht geschrieben ist.
Aber nicht dafür, warum der Code das tut. Mit anderen Worten, sie war völlig wertlos.
Die Kommentare waren so schlecht, dass ich sie auch bei Review-Kommentaren von
menschlichen Kollegen abgelehnt hätte.
Also ich lese sowas immer wieder mal und das Ding ist halt einfach,
da muss man dann halt auch richtig prompten.
Also man kann sehr wohl eine Dokumentation erstellen, die Dinge zusammenfasst
und man muss nicht nur sagen, jetzt mach auch noch mal Kommentare dazu,
das was er jetzt hier beschreibt ist ja eigentlich das was man so in den meisten
Programmen so vorfindet,
Setze A auf 0, A gleich 0. Das hat natürlich keinen Wert, aber man kann eben
auch gezielt Dokumentationen erstellen.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich sogar ganz gut, indem man halt dann auch wirklich
sagt, analysiere diesen Code, sag mir mal, wofür benutzt wird.
Also man muss da eben sehr explizit reingehen.
Das ist einfach eine Erfahrungssache, um es kurz zusammenzufassen.
Nicht, dass ich da jetzt der totale Erfahrungspapst bin.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie relativ viel Zeit da reingesteckt, aber ich sehe halt
schon, dass mit ein bisschen Übung kann man da eben sehr viel Nutzen draus ziehen.
Also Chris, Tim sagt dir, you're prompting it wrong.
You're prompting it wrong. Genau. So sieht es aus.
Syntagma, kommentiert zu KI und Linguistik. Möchtest du das machen?
Ja, das ist auch sehr interessant. Nochmal zu dem LLM-Thema.
Ich habe Linguistik studiert und für mich ist es etwas bedrückend,
dass LLMs eigentlich rein mathematische Modelle sind, die die komplette Forschung
in meinem Fach fast vollständig ignorieren.
Auch in der Computerlinguistik gibt es sehr ausgefeilte Theorien,
um Sprache für den Computer verarbeitbar zu machen.
Die haben ebenfalls komplett keine Relevanz für LLMs. Was allerdings auch stimmt,
wie fast alle KI-Systeme geben auch LLMs kaum Preis darüber, wie sie funktionieren.
Es lassen sich aus LLMs zumindest aktuell noch keine brauchbaren Erkenntnisse
über das Wesen von Sprache ableiten, auch wenn es dazu bereits mittlerweile erste Forschung gibt.
Die praktische Relevanz von LLMs ist enorm, die theoretische für die Linguistik aber eher null.
Oder zumindest sehe ich sie gerade nicht.
Schade ist halt nur, dass wir mit unseren Methoden den LLMs nicht das Wasser reichen können.
Ja, da wirst du nicht der einzige Wissenschaftszweig sein,
der diese Enttäuschung gerade verdauen muss, der mit diesem Schlag in die Magengrube zurechtkommen muss.
Übrigens ja auch wir Menschen selber, dass da jetzt auf einmal was sprechen
kann, klüger ist, mehr Wissen akkumulieren kann, als wir sich besser ausdrücken können.
Ja, aber ich würde auch sagen, genau darin liegt auch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung,
weil der Kommentar ja auch zeigt, dass wissenschaftliche Forschung jetzt nicht
pauschal einfach beiseite gefegt wird.
Also wie sie ja auch oder er sagt, praktische Relevanz ist enorm.
Aber man kann daraus eben keine Schlüsse ziehen, wirklich. Man beobachtet lediglich,
dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Und von daher ist da, glaube ich, auch gerade für die theoretische Forschung
noch eine ganze Menge zu tun.
Ob das dann nochmal seine eigenen Auswirkungen hat, ist ja eine andere Frage.
Ich glaube, wir hatten das auch schon mal erwähnt.
Ich finde es gerade im Zusammenhang mit Linguistik ja sehr interessant,
weil die Linguistik hat diesen Begriff definiert.
Künstliche Intelligenz ist ja etwas, was vor 75 Jahren genau aus der linguistischen
Forschung heraus mal als Proposal an die Wand geschrieben wurde.
Ja, dann könnt ihr jetzt auch nicht quengeln. Das haben wir so bestellt.
Das wird jetzt so gegessen. Zack.
Tja, Zauberlehrlinge, ihr. Wart mal bei der ARD nach, wie das geht.
Okay. Letzter Kommentar von Sebastian.
Ich finde eure anfangs Metagedanken darüber, dass nur noch der Untergang beschworen
wird und Linus Ableitung daraus sich doch individuell mehr mit positiven,
kleineren Dingen zu beschäftigen, interessant und würde hier sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen.
Denn ich habe häufig den Eindruck, dass sich diese Beschäftigung der großen
und damit nicht durch den einzelnen lösbaren Probleme auch als Ausrede genutzt
wird, nicht zu handeln und damit die Verantwortung abzugeben.
Darüber, dass insbesondere in der Politik immer seltener Verantwortung übernommen
wird, müssen wir vermutlich nicht diskutieren. Aber es wird sich mit den unlösbaren
Problemen eine eigene Handlungsunfähigkeit attestiert und man verweilt in einem
Zustand, das ist halt so.
Siehe auch Merz' Aussage, Deutschland habe nur einen geringen Anteil am globalen
CO2-Ausstoß und deswegen muss man nicht handeln.
Und genau aus diesem Zustand müssen wir weg. wenn wir etwas verändern wollen.
Und deshalb finde ich Linus Gedanken
so stark, sich mit den Problemen zu beschäftigen, die wir lösen können.
Und viele kleine gelöste Probleme bringen uns, davon bin ich überzeugt,
gesellschaftlich dann nach vorn.
Mehr Hoffnung im Kleinen, um mehr Hoffnung im Großen zu haben.
Ich hoffe, ihr tragt weiter zu einem Teil dazu bei.
Ja, danke Sebastian. Eine Sache müssen wir sagen. Also eins ist sicher.
Auf jeden Fall viele kleine gelöste Probleme bringen, bringen uns gesellschaftlich
nach vorn, das stimmt, aber bitte vergesst eins nicht, ein gelöstes Problem bringt euch was?
Das nächste Problem. Das ist nur ein besseres. Ja, also das Leben ist ein Streben
nach besseren Problemen.
Ja, es gibt ein Buch, in dem diese Gedanken sehr schön formuliert sind,
das ich empfehlen kann für alle.
Das heißt The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck.
Und da werden derartige Gedanken sehr viel drin behandelt.
Er sagt halt irgendwie so, das ist sehr provokativ geschrieben,
Man sagt halt irgendwie so, ich glaube, er nimmt dann irgendwie als Beispiel so eine, was weiß ich,
ein Bettler und Warren Buffett haben beide Geldprobleme, aber Warren Buffett
hat bessere Geldprobleme,
ja, aber der ist ja trotzdem, Warren Buffett, bis er jetzt aufgehört hat,
sich beruflich mit Geld zu beschäftigen, hat er ein Leben damit verbracht,
Geldprobleme zu lösen.
Und mit dieser Menge an Geld hat er, was meinst du, was der für Geldprobleme hat, der arme Mann?
Es sind halt nur bessere als die, die quasi deine Subsistenz bedrohen.
Und das finde ich eine sehr schöne, aber auf jeden Fall hat Warren Buffett sicherlich
nicht gesagt, dass er ein problemfreies Leben hat, sondern er hat ein,
er würde wahrscheinlich sagen, dass er ein Leben hatte von wunderschönen,
Problemen, die er gelösen konnte.
Oh man, das Buch ist von Mark Manson. Ich habe es nicht gelesen,
aber ich sehe gerade eine Kapitel Zusammenfassung.
Die neuen Kapitel heißen Don't Try. Happiness is a problem.
You are not special. The value of suffering.
You are always choosing. You are wrong about everything, but so am I.
Failure is the way forward. The importance of saying no und das neute Kapitel heißt And Then You Die.
Ich bin überzeugt, dieses Buch wird zu einem besseren Leben führen.
Dieses Buch ist wirklich, nein, also es ist wirklich gut.
Und übrigens dieses mit dem Don't Try, weißt du, was das für eine Quotation ist?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Don't Try ist die Aufschrift auf dem Grabstein von Charles Bukowski,
der ja ein Leben im Prinzip am Ende geführt hat.
Die Bücher von Bukowski handeln ja auch einfach nur so von Menschen voller Plagesichtum,
Suff, Drogenprobleme, irgendwelche.
Das ist ja sein Leben. Und darüber hat er geschrieben. Und damit hat er Jahrzehnte
gelebt als Alkoholkranker, wo sich keine Sau für ihn interessiert hat.
Aber er hat es weitergemacht. Und er hat nur das gemacht, was er getan hat.
Und dann wurde er irgendwann spät entdeckt. Dann ist er ein großer,
großer Star der Literatur geworden.
Nein, quasi ein historischer Literat mit dem, was er getan hat.
Und dieses Don't try,
soll eher ausdrücken, du sollst nicht Dinge versuchen, sondern du sollst Dinge machen.
Du sollst es halt durchziehen mit aller Kraft und allem Glauben und nicht sagen,
ach, ich versuche mal literar zu werden, sondern du machst es einfach bis zum
bitteren Ende und du leidest 40 Jahre und dann bist du irgendwann der Star.
Und das ist halt nicht dieses, du sollst es nicht versuchen,
sondern du sollst diese Mentalität des Versuchens ablegen.
Das fand ich auch sehr inspirierend.
Ja, dazu macht man noch das Machet Einfach Album von Ico und Er an und man hat den perfekten Abend.
Ico und Er aus Spandau, Alter.
Richtig geil. Ich sag's noch. Machet Einfach.
Apropos Spandau, ich war kürzlich in Spandau.
Wirklich?
Ja, ich glaub das ist Spandau, oder?
Das ist... Nee, das ist nicht Spandau. Aber das geht so in dir nicht.
So dermaßen wie Berlin, das ist...
Ich bitte dich.
Also wenn man nach Spandau fährt.
Ist das Charlottengrad oder was?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist Charlottenburg.
Und zwar war ich bei den Wühlmäusen, das ist so ein Kabarett-Theater in West-Berlin,
ein relativ historisches Gebäude, war vorher auch mal irgendwie was anderes.
Und da haben unsere Freunde Nikolas und Reinhardt ihre Bühnenshow von Methodisch Inkorrekt aufgeführt.
Das Imperium schlägt zurück.
Das Imperium.
Und also es ist ja, war das die LMP 200, wo sie das Vorprogramm bei uns gemacht
haben? Ja, ne? Ich glaube, wir haben bei der Minkorrekt 100.
Wir waren bei der 100, das Vorprogramm.
Wir waren bei Ihnen bei der 100 und Sie waren, glaube ich, bei uns bei der 200.
Ich meine schon, ja, ja. Ich bin mir relativ sicher. Es ist lange her.
Und.
Übrigens war der Reini auch bei unserer 500.
Ja.
Aber nur im Publikum. Jedenfalls, genau, unsere Freunde von Methode Tinkorik.
Ich habe nachgeschaut, du hast recht, LMP 200.
Die haben, ja, also das ist, glaube ich, das zweite Mal, dass sie so auf Tour
gehen mit einer Bühnenshow.
Die erste ist schon ein paar Jahre her, das war präpandemisch.
Und ich fand das jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr interessant, weil mir da eins aufgefallen ist.
Also sie behandeln dann auch so ein Verhältnis zu Wahrheit,
Kontextualisierung, wissenschaftliche Erkenntnistheorien. Wie schafft man denn
Wissen? Wie sichert man Wissen ab?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen irgendwas, was irgendwie so dargeboten wird?
Da haben Sie sehr schöne Beispiele, will ich ja jetzt auch nichts spoilern.
Das ist auf jeden Fall unterhaltsam und natürlich auch angereichert mit physikalischen
Experimenten und Feuer.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall machen. Aber was ich krass fand,
so als Eindruck, der mir dann am Ende blieb.
Das ist jetzt eine politische Show. Das ist eine politische Positionierung, die die da machen.
Und dieses wissenschaftliche Denken, überhaupt zu sagen, pass mal auf,
es gibt Realität, wir haben hier so ein paar tausend Jahre,
Menschheitsgeschichte, wir wissen, wie Forschung Gewissen generiert,
wie man Wissen sichert, wie man mit Skeptizismus weiterkommt.
Und für diese Erkenntnis theoretische Grundhaltung ein bisschen zu werben,
ist jetzt was höchst politisches geworden.
Und da habe ich mir so, ich habe sie jetzt nicht damit konfrontiert,
die machen ja auch jetzt bestimmt seit zehn Jahren oder was den Podcast, würde ich schätzen.
Länger, glaube ich.
Und als die angefangen haben, als die da irgendwie an der Uni Duisburg-Essen
saßen und sagten, wir könnten ja mal so einen Podcast machen über Wissenschaft,
ob die damals wussten, dass sie irgendwann verzweifelt quasi durch Deutschland
touren mit wirklich sehr, sehr vielen Auftritten und nichts anderes als eine politische Show,
eine politische Message rüberbringen,
Statt, was weiß ich, hier, guck mal, brennt Feuer lustig, wir erklären uns mal
cooles Phänomen, was ich jetzt unterstelle in meiner naiven Wahrnehmung,
dass das wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal vor zehn oder mehr Jahren,
als sie angefangen haben,
so, ach ja, hör mal, wir machen interessante Sachen,
wir können dir gut erklären, dass mal Menschen so dieses Wissen vermitteln und
dass sie jetzt da hingehen und sagen,
eine Show machen, die letztendlich, das ist eine politische Show.
Und ich Am Ende wird alles LNP.
Nee, aber das war halt für mich so ein eindrücklicher Messwert.
Die erste Bühnenshow von ihnen war ja auch politisch. Die hat ja auch Inhalte
über Esoterik und diesen ganzen Quatsch gehabt, wo sie natürlich steht,
das wissenschaftliche Weltbild,
solchen Anschauungen gegenüber und das sind gefundene Fressen,
da kann man viel Spaß mit haben, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung hat von Realität und aber das war schon,
hätte ich nicht gedacht, weißt du?
Dass sich das so entwickelt, meinst du? Hättest du nicht gedacht?
Ja, ja, dass das was Politisches wird.
Ich hab mich da mit jemand anderem drüber unterhalten und hat so diesen Eindruck
geteilt und sagte so, ja, die machen im Prinzip erklären, die wissenschaftliches
Denken, empirische Wissenschaften.
Und er sagte sofort, ja, aber das ist links. Das ist doch jetzt links.
Ich dachte, man, jetzt du musst mir jede Pointe wegnehmen. Ich wollte das jetzt,
ich wollte das ausführen, aber ja.
Also seit zwölf Jahren sind die jetzt auf Sendung.
Seit zwölf Jahren.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ich konnte leider nicht kommen, weil ich was anderes zu tun hatte, aber mal schauen.
Ich bin zwölf Stunden Anreise hatte ich.
Zwölf Stunden Anreise bis nach Charlottenburg.
Stalingrad, hier Spandau oder was das ist.
Ja, mal gucken. Das ist ja noch eine Weile auf der Reise.
Hier nächste Tourdaten. Bielefeld, Freiburg, Lübeck, Mainz.
Nochmal Mainz, Gießen.
Görn, Fürth, Ollenburg, Osnabrück, Duisburg, Dortmund, ja alles im Westen.
Duisburg?
Die trauen sich überhaupt nicht, ja von wegen Aufklärung, ich meine,
wenn die nicht durch Ostdeutschland fahren, was soll denn das?
Ja, weil die sind halt auf dem Rücken. Nee, aber du musst hochscrollen,
die waren sicherlich, garantiert waren die auch in Sicherheit.
Ja, hochscrollen kann man ja nicht, die schauen nur in die Zukunft, die kümmern sich nicht.
Ja, weil Aber wo in Duisburg?
Wo in Duisburg?
Venue würde mich interessieren.
Ja, scroll, scroll, scroll. Rheinhausenhalle.
Okay.
Aber erst im Februar 26. Die planen weit voraus.
Naja, die haben schon sehr, sehr viele Termine da.
Ja, aber wenn ich die jetzt nochmal sehen will, dann muss ich investen.
Duisburg ist in Ordnung, da sind die Hotels nicht so teuer. Wenn es noch eins gibt.
Na gut. Sehr schön. So, und ja, mit der Bildung und der Aufklärung.
Bildung? Wir müssen uns ja nicht wundern.
Ist auch in Baden-Württemberg ein Problem. Nicht nur dort. Aber man hätte ja
was tun können. Und man hat eigentlich auch was getan.
Aber es konnte nicht kommuniziert werden.
In Baden-Württemberg sind seit 2005, das ist 20 Jahre her,
insgesamt 1.440 Lehrerinnenstellen als belegt ausgewiesen in deren Verwaltungssystem, obwohl sie frei waren.
Das heißt, die hatten einen anerkannten Bedarf an 1.440 Lehrstellen,
die sie ausschreiben wollten, wo sie auch Bewerberinnen gerne gehabt hätten,
die dann einfach nicht besetzt wurden.
Jetzt muss man die Zahlen natürlich ins Verhältnis setzen.
Eine Lehrkraft unterrichtet im Schnitt 27 Stunden pro Woche und,
damit hättest du quasi bei 1.444 mal 27 38.000 Unterrichtsstunden pro Woche
die Baden-Württemberg über 20 Jahre fehlten.
Allerdings, andere Perspektive, an den öffentlichen Schulen werden rund 95.000
Lehrer, Lehrkörper beschäftigt.
Und dann ist natürlich 1.440 nur anderthalb Prozent.
Die haben 4000 Schulen, davon sind 11% privat, also 3560 Schulen.
Damit hat so an jeder zweieinhalbten Schule eine komplette Lehrerin gefehlt.
Alle diese Zahlen übrigens sind aus der Google Zusammenfassung ich habe keine
Quelle dafür, kann auch nicht stimmen die einzige Quelle, die wir verlinken
ist der Postillon die haben die 1440,
Lehrkörper in der Badewanne gefunden, ne nicht in der Badewanne,
in der Turnhalle oder was?
In der Lagerhalle ja also,
man muss dazu sagen, dass diese 1440 Stellen, die sind jetzt nicht seit 20 Jahren
offen weil die mal vor 20 Jahren eingestellt wurden, sondern das hat sich jetzt
so über die Zeit akkumuliert.
Hat sich akkumuliert, ja.
Es wurden also immer wieder Stellen freigegeben und sind aber dann nicht besetzt worden.
Aber nicht, weil sie niemand besetzen wollte, sondern das Ganze ist in der Software hängen geblieben.
Genau, das muss man vielleicht noch dazu erzählen, warum wir uns damit beschäftigen.
Genau, das ist jetzt sozusagen der eigentliche Aspekt. Es ist hier sozusagen
in irgendeiner Form, Und da kann, ich weiß nicht, ob der Fehler jetzt schon
klar ist, aber ist eigentlich auch egal.
Software hat sozusagen dazu geführt, dass diese Stellen dann letzten Endes nicht besetzt wurden.
Und ich meine, es ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, dass sowas in einem Computersystem steht.
Es ist auch nachvollziehbar, dass solche Fehler passieren. Ich finde es bemerkenswert,
dass sie das jetzt auch gefunden haben.
Das hätte noch weitere 30 Jahre da schlummern können.
Da hätte sie keinen Schüler mehr gehabt, der so einen Fehler noch finden kann.
Und ja, keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt ausgeht, aber die eigentliche Frage ist
ja, hätte man das verhindern können?
Ich meine, jetzt reden sie natürlich alle drüber auf, aber Fehler sind halt
Fehler und wenn Fehler halt im Computer passieren, dann die hätten auch genauso
gut in der Bürokratie fehlen können.
Nur so, dass sie natürlich dann hier algorithmisch sind und sich dann eben auch
kontinuierlich wiederholen,
während ein einzelner Fehler bei einer Besetzung, der jetzt durch normale,
manuelle, bürokratische Tätigkeit
nicht besetzt wird, sich eben nicht zwangsläufig genauso wiederholt.
Es sei denn, es ist vorsätzlich.
Ja, jetzt kann man natürlich da mit dem Finger drauf zeigen und sagt, ihr seid ja alle doof.
Was es glaube ich am Ende wirklich aussagt, ist nur, es ist extrem wichtig,
auf Softwarequalität zu achten.
Deswegen lasst euren Code immer schön von der AI kommentieren.
Da kann nichts passieren.
Was ich sagen will ist, an dieser Stelle hat ja in irgendeiner Form die Balance nicht gestimmt.
Also, wenn du so einen Fehler in der Finanzbuchhaltung machst.
Dann hat der Staat keine Gnade.
Und dann hat der Staat keine Gnade, wenn du dich um 1440 Angestellte in deinem
Unternehmen bei den Sozialabgaben, ja, ich meine.
Ja, aber das haben sie einfach schon vor tausenden von Jahren in der Toskana irgendwie gecheckt.
Und bei den Fuggern, doppelte Buchführung ist einfach wichtig,
damit nichts verloren geht.
Und dieser Gedanke muss sich eben auch auf Software hin erweitern,
dass man auch hier immer wieder von vornherein sicherstellt,
da darf nichts verloren gehen.
Ja, also es muss da so Checks und Balances auch geben, sodass man eben sowas nicht verliert.
Ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein bisschen allgemein formuliert und man kann ja hier,
wie gesagt, immer wenn einer so einen Fehler macht, dann haben die anderen halt,
die einen haben den Schaden und die anderen haben die Witze für ihren Podcast.
Und die Gelegenheit, daraus eine Lehre Genau so.
Ganz hochnäsige, ganz hochnäsige, besserwisserische Feststellung.
Ich habe ja schon vor Jahren gesagt.
Ja,
aber das ist halt der Punkt. Da ist das Problem schon mal gelöst worden und
das schon vor sehr langer Zeit.
Na gut.
Die Frage ist, buchst du jetzt so eine Lehrerin als haben oder soll?
Das ist eigentlich egal. Hauptsache du buchst es auf dem anderen Konto auch
andersrum. Darum geht's.
So, dann haben wir über die Software Palantir gesprochen.
Hier in meiner letzten Sendung.
Eine Software aus dem Hause Die Software heißt ja anders.
Das Haus ist quasi Palantir und die Software heißt je nachdem.
Und diese Firma gehört Peter Thiel,
eine im Zweifelsfall KI-gestützte Software oder mit irgendeiner Form von Fuzzy
Logic arbeitende Software, der die mehrere Daten,
Banken und Datensammlungen, die potenziell einer Polizei zugänglich sind,
zusammenführt und mit einem vereinheitlichten Suchinterface versieht.
So ist es beschrieben.
Die sogenannte automatisierte Datenanalyse beispielsweise im bayerischen Polizeigesetz.
Und die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, unter anderem mit Unterstützung des Chaos Computer Clubs,
hat eine Verfassungsbeschwerde in Bayern formuliert und jetzt ist die Frage
warum und das ist mir sehr gar nicht so.
Uninteressant, es ist nicht, weil es von einem rechtsradikalen Durchgeknallten namens Peter Thiel ist,
es ist nicht der Kern des Problems, sondern dass eben diese unterschiedlichen
Datenquellen zusammengeführt und
dann nach neuen Maßstäben oder nach neuen Suchbegriffen gerastert werden.
Also dass du quasi eine Rasterfahndung über diese Datenbestände machst aus den
verschiedenen Datenbanken.
Und wie du das machst, das ist nicht öffentlich nachvollziehbar.
Aber welche Daten unter welchen Bedingungen in diese automatisierte Analyse
einfließen dürfen, ist durchaus eine
Frage, denn es gibt eine Zweckbindung polizeilich aufgenommener Daten.
Und wenn du die jetzt im Prinzip automatisiert und damit natürlich auch zwecklos
oder nicht mehr zweckgebunden zusammenführst,
dann untergräbst du die Zweckbindung der Datenerfassung.
Und wenn insbesondere in solchen Polizeigesetzen Befugnisse gegeben werden,
irgendwelche Daten zu erfassen, dann wird auch immer ein Zweck dafür benannt.
Das wird ja, wir dürfen die machen, aber nur um das zu machen.
Oder du darfst in diese und jene Datenbank, aber nur um zu verhindern,
dass du nochmal ins Stadion kommst und da am Roulettetisch dein Vermögen aufs Spiel setzt oder so.
Also um eine andere Datenbank zu nennen, nämlich die für die Spielsüchtigen.
Und das heißt, diese Datensammlungen sind zweckgebunden und wenn du jetzt eine
automatisierte Massenanalyse über unterschiedliche Daten, die zu unterschiedlichen
Zwecken gesammelt wurden.
Einrichtest, dann untergräbst du die Zweckbindung dieser Datensammlung,
die und damit auch ihre letztendlich legislative Legitimation,
warum es überhaupt jemals den Sicherheitsbehörden erlaubt wurde,
diese Daten zu erfassen.
Ist das, ist das?
Ja, ich kann dir folgen, ich frage mich nur, in welchem Stadion ein Roulette-Tisch steht.
Es ging mir darum, die Datenbank Gewalttäter Sport mit dieser spielsüchtigen Datenbank ...
Habe ich schon verstanden. Mir ging es nur darum, vielleicht einen Witz zu machen.
Ach so, ja. Oder wenn du demnächst in der Register für psychisch Kranke,
wenn man jetzt die Datenbank mit bestimmten nicht genannten Fußballstadien verbinden
würde, dann kommt da die Hälfte nicht mehr rein.
Und da ist dann eben die Zweckbindung in dieser nicht zweckdienlichen Anwendung
wird eben automatisch untergraben.
Und ich glaube, diese Argumentation ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Und deswegen hat die GFF eben auch diese Verfassungsbeschwerde jetzt formuliert,
eingereicht und bin sehr gespannt.
Es gibt dann natürlich acht Beschwerdeführerinnen, weil da müssen ja immer Leute,
die spezifisch betroffen sind, eine Strafverteidigerin, Aktivistin,
Fanhilfe, Fußballverein, deswegen kam ich drauf, der Spielvereinigung Gräuter-Fürth,
oder heißt es jetzt Fürth? Hier steht nur Fürth.
Gräuter-Fürth, oder?
Spielvereinigung Gräuter-Fürth.
Ja, hier steht nur Fürth. Der Beschwerdeführer ist Johannes König,
ein Musiker und Mitorganisator der Demonstration gegen das Bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz.
Der sagte, als wäre das Bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz noch nicht autoritär
genug, setzt die Staatsregierung nun auch noch auf die Überwachungssoftware
des rechten Verschwörungsideologen Peter Thiel.
Diese Entwicklung muss in Karlsruhe gestoppt werden. Und ja,
schauen wir mal, wie das gelingt.
Jetzt kommen wir in die Abteilung, richtige Dinge aus den falschen Gründen tun.
Und von den falschen Leuten.
Von den falschen Leuten. Und man wundert sich, warum eigentlich.
Aber so scheint es gekommen zu sein.
Was ist der Hintergrund? Der Hintergrund ist der, dass es in dem Vereinigten
Königreich seit längerem die Bestrebungen gibt, große Technikanbieter dazu zu
zwingen, ihre Verschlüsselung offen zu legen.
Also keine Vollverschlüsselung, die der Staat nicht einsehen kann,
zu unternehmen, also eine Backdoor zu machen. Wir hatten das glaube ich auch
schon mal darüber berichtet.
Geht mal wieder konkret um Apple, die halt hier gezwungen wurden das zu tun
und die daraufhin ihr Advanced Data Protection,
also das ist der Modus, den man so für seine iCloud einschalten kann,
dass eben wirklich alles komplett verschlüsselt ist und Apple dann eben dir
auch gar keinen Zugang mehr geben kann, wenn du deine eigenen Schlüssel verlierst,
dass sie das ausgeschaltet haben in UK, um nicht erst in die Situation zu kommen,
solche Schlüssel herauszugeben.
Und da ging es dann auch die ganze Zeit hin und her. Jetzt hat aber UK diese Pläne begraben. Warum?
Weil sich die Trump-Regierung beschwert hat und gesagt hat, was erlaube UK,
unsere tollen, superschönen amerikanischen Tech-Unternehmen zu regulieren.
Das ist ja gerade so, ihr Ding, dass sie jetzt alle bedrohen und sagen, hier keine Ahnung, wir.
Zöller, keine Waffen mehr, kein was auch immer, also alles, was bisher immer
selbstverständlich war, wird jetzt in Frage gestellt und zu einer Drohgebärde umgewandelt.
Was jetzt hier genau gedroht wurde, weiß ich natürlich nicht,
da wird sehr viel hinter den Kulissen gelaufen sein.
Tatsache ist, dass eben jetzt UK hier einen Schritt nach hinten macht und sagt,
okay, sorry, tut uns leid, machen wir nicht.
Ob du Kommentare bekommst, ob 100% alles verschlüsselt ist in der Advanced Data
Protection, kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber auf jeden Fall Dateien und so.
Also würde jemand alle Passwörter haben, ohne ein Gerät, auf dem auch ein Kryptoschlüssel
zur Entschlüsselung der Daten ist, dann wäre sehr viel nicht mehr zugreifbar,
insbesondere auch zum Beispiel deine Device Backups, wenn man die da hochschiebt.
Genau, das war die Snoopers Charter, glaube ich, hieß das Gesetz,
das mit dem UK Apple zu dem Schritt gezwungen hat, die Aktivierung dieses Features zu verhindern.
Also diejenigen, die es hatten, denen konnten sie es natürlich auch nicht ausschalten,
weil die Daten waren ja nur mal verschlüsselt.
Und jetzt hat sich die Privatspende von Tim Apple an Donald Trump gelohnt.
Ja, genau. Also es ist der UK Investigatory Powers Act, unter dem das läuft.
Snoopers Charter ist so, ja, der versucht das.
Ja klar, das war nicht der offizielle Name.
So, dann wurden wir auf eine große EU-Petition oder Citizens Initiative hingewiesen,
die erstaunlich große Reichweite und auch erstaunlich große Anhängerschaft erlangt hat.
Also ich glaube über eine Million Unterschriften oder über 1,4 Millionen Signaturen,
wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe. 1,4,
1.424.115. Das wird auch immer mehr.
Und da merkt man, da geht es um was richtig Wichtiges.
Computerspiele.
Und aber ja, es geht um Computerspiele, aber ich glaube, das Phänomen geht auch
nicht nur in diesem Bereich. Also,
die Petition sagt, die Menschen, die Computerspiele oder Verlage,
die Computerspiele in Umlauf bringen,
zerstören die in zunehmendem Maße.
Und dir werden zwar die Computerspiele als Produkt verkauft zu einem einmaligen
Preis, ohne dass ein Ablaufdatum dran steht,
aber sie sind so gestaltet, dass sie komplett unspielbar werden,
sobald der Support von dem Verlag endet.
Ich glaube, damit sind so Sachen gemeint wie, oder letztendlich natürlich Sachen
gemeint wie Spiele, die konstante Online-Ressourcen brauchen.
Und die in dem Moment, wo es irgendwie für den Verlag nicht mehr rentabel ist,
wenn der seine Server abschaltet, kannst du eben auch dieses Spiel nicht mehr spielen.
Und sagen, das ist natürlich eine Form der geplanten Obsoleszenz.
Und es ist natürlich ein Problem für die Kundinnen und Kunden,
klar, die haben ein Produkt gekauft, dieses Produkt funktioniert jetzt nicht
mehr, aber sie argumentieren auch,
wir können ja diese Kulturgüter nicht mehr,
verwahren und es ist ja durchaus, sag ich mal, eine nicht unwichtige Sache,
wenn ich beispielsweise mir ein Commodore 64 auf Ebay kaufe,
und dann meine drei Lieblingsspiele, die für mich damals eine Rolle gespielt
haben, sowas wie Gianna Sisters und Outrun und was ich da nicht alle,
Bubble Bobble und so, diese Kulturgüter.
Mit der Absicht kaufe,
damit irgendwann mal zu spielen und sie dann, natürlich niemals dazu komme,
weil ich gar keinen Fernseher habe,
wo man das anschließen könnte, aber dass ich dann durch meine Akquisition zur
Präservation dieses Kulturgutes für zehn Jahre beitrage, um es dann wieder auf
Ebay zu verkaufen, ungeprüft und ungespielt,
aber dass diese Kultur erhalten wir, also hier Retro-Computing-Festivals und
so, und ich denke, wir müssen auf jeden Fall.
Erkennen und anerkennen, dass Computerspiele Kulturgüter sind,
wenn nicht sogar die vielleicht höchsten Kulturgüter,
die wir so in der Geschichte der Menschheit hervorgebracht haben,
wenn man ihre Komplexität, individuellen Nutzungsmöglichkeiten,
Interaktionen über die Welt, da kann man schon fragen, ob jetzt irgendwie Leonardo,
hast du nicht gesehen, ein schöneres Bild gemalt hat oder ob quasi,
Kulturphänomene wie Grand Theft Auto nicht durchaus eine viel größere Prägung
für Generationen und Lifestyle gestaltet haben.
Und wenn die halt von dem Goodwill eines Publishers abhängen,
der dann sagt, ach nee, das machen wir jetzt kaputt, wir zerstören jetzt die
Möglichkeit, das zu spielen,
dann ist das durchaus ein Problem.
Und das hat natürlich auch in anderen Bereichen ein Problem.
Ja, und letztendlich, ich meine, es geht darum, dass die Server haben,
auf denen diese Spiele funktionieren, die irgendwie zentrale Rollen in der Funktion des Spiels haben.
Und wenn sie die ausschalten, dann funktioniert das Spiel nicht mehr.
Und natürlich wäre eine Lösung zu sagen, naja, okay, wenn du dich entscheidest,
damit kein Geld mehr zu verdienen oder kein Geld mehr verlieren zu wollen,
dann kannst du ja wenigstens denen eine Archivierung dieses Kulturgutes ermöglichen.
Ja, also das ist natürlich...
Ein Bild von Leonardo da Vinci ist relativ einfach zu erhalten,
dass man das noch genießen kann.
Man kann darüber diskutieren, mit welchem Aufwand man das treiben soll.
Muss 3D gescannt werden und was nicht alles?
Oder reicht es einfach, das Bild irgendwo hinzuhängen? Bei Spielen ist es natürlich
schwierig, weil diese Spiele von technischen Systemen abhängen.
Wo es in der Natur der Sache liegt, dass sie sehr volatil sind.
Also Technologie entwickelt sich die ganze Zeit weiter, wir wissen alles wie
das ist, auch Webseiten halten nicht lange, Browser ändern sich etc.
Also die technische Entwicklung ist halt sehr schnell auf der einen Seite,
was so Betriebssysteme vor allem angeht.
Auf der anderen Seite, wie du schon erwähnt hast, viele Spiele brauchen auch so Backends.
Da läuft dann einfach Software und um die wirklich spielen zu können,
müssen relativ große Systeme betrieben werden,
wenn es dann halt so ein Unternehmen nicht mehr gibt oder wenn eben so ein Unternehmen
nicht die Ressourcen hat, weil es sozusagen kaum noch jemand spielt und dann
lohnt es sich nicht, zehn Leute dafür zu beschäftigen, das noch im Laufen zu
halten oder wie viele auch immer erforderlich sind.
Dann ist das natürlich halt so eine Forderung, wo man sagen kann,
naja, kann man jetzt Unternehmen dazu verpflichten, auf Ewigkeiten sozusagen
eine Dienstleistung bereitzustellen?
Ist das deren Aufgabe? Also da würde mich mal die technische Antwort darauf interessieren.
Also was Sie möchten ist, dass Sie sagen...
Wenn die Companies sagen, sie möchten die Unterstützung für dieses Spiel beenden,
dann sollen sie eben verpflichtet sein, dieses Spiel entweder so zu konvertieren,
dass es entweder einen Offline-Modus oder einen Private-Hosting-Modus hat.
Ja, was auch noch mal eine umfangreiche Software-Development nach sich ziehen
müsste und ja dann am Ende auch nicht das Spiel ist, was es vorher war.
Also das wird sich dabei zwangsläufig ja auch verändern.
Ja, aber es wäre immerhin nicht getötet. Ich kann dem Gedanken schon was abgewinnen.
Also nehmen wir mal Minecraft.
Ich habe jetzt lange kein Minecraft mehr gespielt, aber ich weiß,
dass es oder es war zumindest so, als ich mich damit immer auseinandergesetzt
habe, dass du einen Minecraft-Server lokal betreiben, im Internet betreiben oder sonst was kannst.
Und wo quasi diese Multiplayer-Komponente,
offenbar frei ist, frei verteilt wird. Es gibt andere, die sagen,
okay, du möchtest was, was ich Ultima Online spiele, oder wie solche,
oder irgendwelche MMORPGs heißen, wo du,
wo das Modell ist, dass du monatlich zahlst für Zugang zu dieser Welt und wenn
da nicht mehr genug Leute spielen, schalten die es eben ab.
Die sagen dann, wenn ihr es abschaltet, komm, dann geht es wenigstens raus,
um die Konservierung dieses Kulturgutes zu ermöglichen.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall schwierig. Also muss man, wenn man jetzt erwartet,
dass da eine politische Bewegung entsteht, in einem Bereich,
der so hochtechnologisch verankert ist.
Moment, die politische Bewegung ist schon da. Ich meine, die haben 1,4 Millionen Unterschriften.
Bewegung im politischen System entsteht und das aufgreift und sagt,
oh ja, Kulturgut und so weiter, Spiele, wir haben ja auch Spiele gespielt,
sehen wir ja total ein. Dann kommt natürlich als erstes die Frage, was sollen wir tun?
Und das muss dann schon sehr konkret werden und ich habe jetzt gerade mal nur
so zwei, drei Sachen aufgezählt, wo ich jetzt auch keine Antwort drauf hätte.
Also es ist halt auch so diese Forderung mit, naja dann macht ihr das halt Open Source.
Das geht halt teilweise nicht, weil da eben, also das mag gehen manchmal,
das mag aber manchmal auch nicht gehen, weil dann Urheberrecht und Lizenzvereinbarung
und keine Ahnung irgendwelche anderen Dinge dazukommen oder dass bestimmte Computersysteme
dafür existieren müssen,
die dann vielleicht irgendwann auch nicht mehr so existieren.
Es kann natürlich auch beispielsweise eine Rolle spielen, dass der Anbieter
sagt, ach ja, wir haben halt jetzt eine Nachfolgeversion und wir kündigen jetzt mal an,
dass wir die alte Version, das machen wir halt in einem Jahr aus.
Da müsst ihr halt jetzt Ultima oder was auch immer, einen weiter.
Oder No Man's Sky oder wie Spiele heißen, die die starke Abhängigkeit von Serverkomponenten haben.
Ja.
Ich glaube, hier wird halt generell darauf hingewiesen, dass natürlich,
wenn dir etwas als Produkt und nicht als Subscription verkauft wird,
dass das halt ein Problem ist.
Deswegen wird es ja auch immer weniger verkauft.
Übrigens bei der neuen Nintendo Switch 2 spielt es ja auch eine Rolle,
dass sie dir im Prinzip kaum noch ein Spiel verkaufen.
Also im Sinne von, wie das vorher war. hast du eine Cartridge gekauft,
die konnte man da reinstecken und jetzt sind da eigentlich,
irgendwelche Key-Materialien drauf, mit denen du den Besitz dieses Spiels gegenüber
dem Store nachweist, damit der nicht sagt, ich brauche erst eine Buchung von deiner Kreditkarte.
Und das ist ja auch mit Sicherheit wird sich dieses, genau dieses Problem bei
dieser Switch 2 früher oder später stellen,
dass man die nämlich nicht wegen halt umfänglicher Online-Abhängigkeiten auch
für Local-Spiele nicht 30 Jahre,
konservieren und dann auspacken kann und mit ihr spielen kann.
Während das mit dem Gameboy 30 Jahre, da sagt er, was ist los,
Alter? Ich bin brandneu.
Ich brauche nur vier neue Batterien.
Technologie ändert sich halt.
Aber ja, das ist etwas, was diese Menschen will. Ich denke, es ist ein,
wenn man diesen Kulturgut Perspektive da hat, dann ist die nicht verkehrt.
Die können dann ihre Serverfarm in ein Museum stellen.
Weil wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hat ja Mark kommentiert, dass unsere,
Energieverfügbarkeit durch Photovoltaik eh steigt, dann kann ja demnächst irgendwann
so ein Museum dann halt die alte Serverfarm da wieder hinstellen.
Ja, ich sage nur, fordern ist immer einfach, aber wenn man einen politischen
Prozess wirklich in Gang bringen will, dann ist es eben auch erforderlich,
den dann auch weiterhin zu begleiten, weil der sonst schnell ausstehbar.
Aber die Forderung haben wir ja formuliert, die sagen halt, okay,
wenn du sagst, du möchtest eine Handlung unternehmen, die es jetzt quasi anderen
unmöglich macht, das bei dir gekaufte Produkt weiter zu nutzen,
das bei dir gekaufte Kulturprodukt weiter zu nutzen,
dann musst du es in irgendeiner Weise eine Konservierung und Weiternutzung ermöglichen.
Solange Leute noch Spiele als Produkt verkaufen, schon spielt das eine Rolle,
aber ich meine, es wird ja eh alles nur noch in Richtung Subscription gehen.
Die QI gibt auf.
Die Zentralstelle Urheberrecht im Internet,
die haben ja, das ist ja im Prinzip ein Internetsperrenkartell,
ohne juristische und erst recht nicht legislative Grundlage.
Und die haben dann irgendwie in dieser Zentralstelle, also irgendwas Urhebericht im Internet.
Und die pflegen Sperrlisten.
Die sie auf ihren DNS-Servern verwenden und quasi dass die dort mitmachenden sich entscheiden,
zum Beispiel jokerguide.com oder kinox.fun zu sperren,
ist halt irgendwie so im Prinzip eine, das machen die einfach.
Und was sie sperren, haben sie aber keine öffentliche Liste.
Und wir hatten hier schon darüber gesprochen vor einiger Zeit,
dass Lina diese Liste dann quasi reversed und geprüft hat und veröffentlicht hat unter qiliste.de.
Das hat zu einer Rüge durch die Bundesnetzagentur geführt, die eben sagt, hier Moment mal,
Ihr behindert hier Verzeichnisdienste nach Gutdünken in einem nicht geregelten
Prozess, in einem Kartell, würde ich das nennen. Das könnt ihr so nicht machen.
Und interessanterweise hat die Kui jetzt auch quasi gesagt, ja okay,
dann lassen wir das sein.
Und wir akzeptieren, dass es eben jetzt Gerichtsentscheide geben muss für die
Sperrung von Webseiten.
Würdest du sagen, dass das eine gute Nachricht ist?
Mama.
Die gute Nachricht. Besser später als nie.
Und dann kommen wir zum letzten Funklöcher.
Die haben ja Funklöchermessungen gemacht. Da haben sie irgendwie,
ich glaube, war da auch die Bundesnetzagentur oder was?
Nee. Wer hat da denn gemacht?
Mobilfunkmesswoche. 150.000 Menschen haben mit der Bundesnetzagentur die Mobilfunkqualität
in Deutschland untersucht.
Haben irgendwie so eine App gehabt, die quasi GPS und was habe ich hier gerade
für einen Empfang linkt.
Und Ergebnis ist, 98% der Messpunkte, die die Nutzerinnen dabei getragen haben,
haben entweder 4G oder 5G.
Funklöcher gab es in weniger als einem Prozent der erfassten Messpunkte.
In einigen Gebieten zeigen sich aber durchaus größere Versorgungslücken.
Im Schnitt ist es nur ein Prozent.
Und ich glaube, dann war das so, die größten Lücken gibt es in Baden-Württemberg
und Rheinland-Pfalz so mit 1,12 Prozent.
Deutschlandweit sind es halt nur 0,76.
In 1,27% der Messungen war nur ein 2G-Netz verfügbar, was ja eigentlich Funkloch heißt.
Und 2,25% ist diese nur 2G-Abdeckung zum Beispiel in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Also da wurde zumindest mal, das heißt nicht,
dass da guter Service war, Aber da heißt das Handy hat es zumindest geschafft,
sich mit dieser jeweiligen Mobilfunkgeneration zu verbinden und das herzustellen,
was ein erfolgreicher Verbindungsaufbau ist.
Und nicht zu sagen, es gibt kein Netz, wie bei dieser Frau, die da im Outback
unterwegs war. Da gibt es kein Netz.
Bei uns gibt es nur scheiß Empfang. und richtig kein Netz ist halt nicht so
viel. Im Harz gibt es kein Netz.
Teilweise. Ja, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also ah, das ist interessant.
Das wollte ich nämlich gerade, insgesamt haben die durch die gemeldeten Daten
rund 16% der Bundesfläche erfasst.
Also die Stichprobe, die hier ausgewertet wurde, betrifft ungefähr 15% der Fläche
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Okay. Also sie haben jetzt mal bei 15% von Deutschland mal nachgeschaut, ob es da ein Netz gibt.
Hurra, dann warte ich nochmal, bis die anderen 85% auch mal geguckt haben, wie es denn da aussieht.
Weil ich glaube, da bin ich immer unterwegs.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Was sie natürlich nicht gemacht haben, ist, dazu gesagt, mit welcher SIM-Karte,
weil es gibt da natürlich einen Unterschied. Und mit deinem Provider,
Funkloch Unlimited, das ist ja, also ich meine,
tut mir leid.
Naja, deswegen sollten wir halt mal endlich mal klar machen,
dass wenn jetzt so ein Gebiet nicht versorgt ist und mir kann man nicht erzählen,
dass man jetzt irgendwie, seit wann gibt es Mobilfunknetze?
Seit Anfang der 90er Jahre. Sagen wir mal 95 ging das vielleicht mal so nennenswert
los. Hatten wir da irgendwann so E-Plus und so.
95, das ist jetzt 30 Jahre her.
30 Jahre. Und in 30 Jahren gibt es irgendwie keine Methode, wie man irgendwie
feststellen kann, dass es irgendwo kein Netz gibt.
Das kann wohl mal nicht euer Ernst sein.
Und wirklich, also da gehe ich nicht mit. Dann reden sie hier von Messpunkten.
Ich brauche keine Messpunkte. Ich brauche Messflächen. Man muss einfach mal
kategorisch rumfahren, weil Google fährt irgendwie zwei, drei Monate durch Deutschland
und hat irgendwie Fotos von allem.
Können wir nicht erzählen, dass man nicht, wenn man mal mit einer Herrscher von,
nur mal auf den Straßen, ich rede ja noch gar nicht mal von den Wäldern,
das kann man auch irgendwie machen, aber das ist wird die ganze Zeit befahren
in Deutschland. Das muss besser gehen.
Und es ist halt einfach absurd. Und wenn es jetzt wirklich eine Fläche gibt, wo...
Die Provider nicht rein investieren und das kann man halt mal dadurch entforcen,
dass die dann zu bezahlen haben, wenn sie das nicht abdecken,
dann sollen die sich halt einigen dürfen, dass sie sagen, wir stellen jetzt,
okay, hier ist so wenig los, wir stellen hier einen Mast auf und den zahlen
halt alle, alle Betreiber und alle können sich dann da auch einbuchen.
Das ist so einfach. Ich meine, im Ausland kann ich mir auch in jeden Mast einbuchen.
Ja, natürlich. Klasse ist als,
jetzt kommen wir in die Mobilfunkregulierung.
Wenn du bei 1&1 gerade Mobilfunkkunde bist und 5G-Netz hast,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dir das über einen 1&1-Mast,
bereitgestellt wird, verschwindend gering.
Die haben ja ein National Roaming-Angebot.
In Anspruch genommen, aber eben mit besonderer Erlaubnis der Bundesnetzagentur,
damit sie überhaupt in der Lage sind, ein Versorgungsangebot zu machen.
Ja, okay, aber ey, 1,12 Prozent. Ich kann dir sagen, bei mir im Erdgeschoss
haben sie nicht gemessen.
Da ist nämlich 100% vorkloch.
Und ich war auch in den letzten Wochen wieder an so einigen Orten, da ist einfach nichts.
Sorry. Und es kann nicht so schwierig sein, das nichts festzustellen.
Ach, so wird's. Gut, komm, wir machen jetzt hier einen Deckel drauf auf die Sendung.
Ja. Ich kann dich, ich höre mich jetzt auch doppelt.
Ich habe echt hohe im Ohr.
Das ist schon lustig.
Funklöcher, ey, das Thema.
Also, ich kann dir das aussprechen.
Die Bundesnetzagentur hatte ja auch einen Stand da, ne? Und ich konnte nicht
an mich halten. Ich musste da hingehen.
Auf der Republika-Messe.
Du bist da hingegangen, weil das die Bundesnetzagentur war?
Nein, ich bin da hingegangen und da war auch die Bundesnetzagentur mit einem Stand vertreten.
Was wollten die verkaufen?
Na, die haben informiert.
Also über Funklöcher.
Ich bin da hingegangen und habe die auch mal informiert. Nämlich über meine
Meinung zu dem ganzen Thema.
Und habe, glaube ich, irgendwie so einen fünfminütigen Rand abgelassen und sie
tat mir ein bisschen leid, aber sie haben mir zu verstehen gegeben,
dass sie verstehen, dass sie verstehen,
worüber ich rede und sie würden es auch gerne anders haben, aber es ist halt
die Politik, die ihre Guidelines macht und die versteht es halt nicht ganz so.
Tim, kannst du nicht irgendwelche Meta-Host-Testen anpassen?
Das waren keine mehr. Das waren Menschen von der Bundesnetzagentur.
Die auch in einem Fall auch, wo ich auch den Eindruck gewonnen habe,
dass sie dieses Programm hören und still nickten und hatten sie auch ein bisschen leid.
Datenelche? Das wäre doch mal was. Datenelche von der Bundesnetzagentur.
Genau. Ihr müsst nicht messen, ihr müsst einfach die Elche loslassen.
Insbesondere in diesen 2,25% von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Das ist nämlich ihr natives Wildgebiet. Ja, da gehören die hin.
Da werden die halt immer geschossen von irgendwelchen Wavies.
Okay.
Leute, das war's. Bis dann.
Ciao, ciao.
Die Wafis sind Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, die die Datenhälke schießen.
Oh Mann.